- [Voiceover] Hey there.
Today I'm gonna cover the impacts
of agricultural practices.
And to do so, I'm gonna take
you through my morning ritual.
It sounds weird, but my
bowl of multigrain Cheerios,
and rice milk, and relaxing
in my super comfy pajamas,
they're all connected to
intensive agricultural practices,
in particular tilling,
slash and burn farming,
and fertilizers.
So let's take a closer look
at the Cheerios in my bowl.
Most of my cereal here is
actually composed of grains
like oats, corn and
barley, and growing grains
typically starts with
tilling in good quality soil
with lots of nutrients.
But what is tilling?
In short, tilling is the
process of turning soil,
and it's really useful
because loosening the soil
allows farmers to easily control weeds
and other pests at the
surface of the soil,
and it helps them to prepare
the soil for seeding.
Sometimes in areas that
have been heavily farmed,
the soil can become compacted over time.
Here, tilling can help
to break down the soil
into smaller pieces,
called soil aggregates,
and allow for easier crop planting.
Now, tillage has been done
for thousands of years,
but it's changed a lot from the past
when we used human labor
and big draft animals
to till small fields,
usually once per year.
Nowadays, in the era of
industrialized agriculture,
large-scale farmers use
heavy mechanized equipment
that can till thousands of
acres multiple times per year.
Okay, we're growing more so
we're tilling more, a lot more.
And while soil tillage can
help to loosen and aerate soil,
what do you think happens
when heavy machinery
passes over the land
and tears up the surface
multiple times per year?
This practice of repeated
intensive tilling
compacts the lower layers of the soil
and loosens the top soil to the point that
it loses the ability to hold
water and nutrients in place.
Tillage also reduces any
leftover crop residue
like plant stocks.
So, in turn, the exposed soil surface
becomes really vulnerable
to wind and rain,
because nothing is really
holding the soil down
or providing cover.
So, what happens next?
Loose soil can start to
collect in surface runoff
and become displaced through erosion.
When this happens, soil, organic matter,
and nutrients are literally
washed or blown away.
Who would have thought that these Cheerios
were doing so much damage?
But, there's some good news here too.
Low till or no till farming alternatives
can alleviate some of
these problems thankfully.
In the Palouse, a huge
agricultural area in the Western US
where a lot of grains, just
like the ones in my cereal,
are grown.
No till farming is really
important because the fields are,
well, they're really steep and hilly
and wind and rain can
cause a lot of erosion
when the soil is heavily tilled.
By not tilling the fields,
farmers can prevent soil erosion,
and, more importantly,
from my perspective,
make sure that they can grow
lots of grains for my Cheerios
But wait, cereals aren't
complete without milk.
Now, I personally like rice milk
because I'm lactose sensitive,
and rice is commonly grown in temperate
and tropical regions,
oftentimes in areas where
soil quality isn't the best
and nutrients are lacking.
So, how do farmers get
nutrients back into the soil?
And, more importantly,
how do they grow rice
for my rice milk at breakfast?
Well, they often use
slash and burn farming.
So, like the name, forest
plots are slashed or cut,
left to dry and then burned.
The ash left over from the
burning fertilizes the soil.
But, it's only a temporary benefit.
After about three to five years,
the productivity of
slashed and burned plots
goes down really quickly
due to the loss of nutrients
and as weeds start to grow again.
When this happens, farmers
simply abandon the field,
move over to a new area
and repeat the process.
But it can take decades
for these plots to recover
once they've been slashed,
burned, and farmed,
and this practice can
become a vicious cycle.
In the Amazon, for example,
people in rural areas
rely on slash-and-burn so
that they can make money
selling the crops they grow
or create open pastures
for animals to graze.
In the process, thousands of
acres are burned each year.
And as these trees and plants burn,
enormous amounts of greenhouse gases,
mainly carbon dioxide are produced,
which contribute to climate change.
And, sometimes too, fires
may not be well-managed
and can burn out of control
causing huge, costly wildfires.
But it's not all doom and gloom
when it comes to my tasty rice milk.
There are alternatives to slash and burn
which include applying
animal fertilizer like manure
on used plots to add
nutrients back to the soil
or using alley cropping in
which trees or other vegetation
are planted between crops
to help keep nutrients
and moisture in the soil.
All right, by now I've eaten my breakfast
and I'm relaxing in my
super comfy cotton pajamas,
but turns out that cotton is actually
a really finicky crop to grow
and it requires a lot of fertilizers.
And fertilizers help plants grow,
but that's not a bad thing, right?
And it's not.
In fact, we've been using
fertilizers for a millennia.
For thousands of years, people
have used natural fertilizers
to replenish or increase
nutrients in the soil
and promote plant growth.
Natural fertilizers meant
that farmers use things
like leftover crops, manure,
wood ash, ground bones,
fish or fish parts, and bird and bat poop.
In the early 1800s though,
scientists discovered
that nitrogen, phosphorus, and potassium
were key to plant growth.
And in time, many farmers began to switch
from natural fertilizers
to artificial fertilizers
with higher concentrations
of these nutrients
which greatly increased crop yields.
In other words, farmers could grow more,
and that means more cotton
and more comfy pajamas.
But, there's a catch.
Now that farmers are growing more crops
than any time in history, we've learned
that there are impacts
to using large amounts
of very concentrated fertilizers.
Applying too much fertilizer
can pollute runoff water
with excess fertilizer and
pollute local surface waters.
As nutrient rich materials like fertilizer
make their way into nearby
rivers, lakes, and oceans,
they can cause major problems
in the balance of nutrients
in marine ecosystems.
When too many nutrients from fertilizers
saturate a body of water,
called eutrophication,
these nutrients feed the
rapid growth of algae.
In turn, these massive algae blooms
can suck up all the
oxygen in bodies of water
and lead to enormous fish
die-offs called dead zones.
Quite a morbid situation
and very different
from the happy unicorns of my pajamas.
But, there's ways to reduce
the amount of fertilizers
released into waterways.
Farmers can limit the amount
of fertilizer that they apply
or use compost, which is
decomposed organic material,
as a fertilizer which tends
to have lower and safer levels
of nitrates and phosphates.
And, there you have it.
Common agricultural
practices and their impacts
in a nutshell, or
really, a bowl of cereal.